- Over a decade ago,
our next guest spent some time
singing alongside her family
in Central Park.
Then she was discovered by Jay-Z.
Never heard of him.
She's gone on to become a
Grammy-winning songwriter
and critically acclaimed singer.
Now performing, "I Don't Have to Pretend"
off her latest album, "Glory Hour,"
Give it up for Victory, everybody.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
♪ Hold me near ♪
♪ I know that You hear me ♪
♪ My eyes crying tears ♪
♪ My heart in humility ♪
♪ Plead my case, I pour my complaints ♪
♪ Here at the altar ♪
♪ Why should I carry this weight ♪
♪ Why should I suffer
when I have a Savior ♪
♪ Who intimately cares for my sake ♪
♪ Yes, I have a Savior who
came to bear this grief ♪
♪ In my place ♪
♪ I don't have to pretend
like everything's okay ♪
♪ That's not what Jesus meant
when He said to have faith ♪
♪ If you see me crying, I'm being true ♪
♪ Instead of lying about
what I'm going through ♪
♪ I'm trusting God to
heal my every wound ♪
♪ And I know He will ♪
♪ He makes all things new ♪
♪ All things new ♪
♪ I don't have to pretend
like everything's okay ♪
♪ That's not what Jesus meant
when He said to have faith ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ If you see me crying, I'm being true ♪
♪ Instead of lying about
what I'm going through ♪
♪ I'm trusting God to
heal my every wound ♪
♪ And I know He will ♪
♪ He makes all things new ♪
♪ I trust you to make all things new ♪
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh.
Once more, put your hands
together for Victory, y'all!
Pick up album "Glory Hour"
wherever you get your music.
Beautiful cover.
We'll be right back with What I'm Liking.